hello it's me there's no time to explain
I don't have time to do the whole
Preamble of this is in the future this
in the past I just have enough time to
wait for people to get in here because
you're probably wondering where I've
been for the past week
I've been working on my mom's
documentary I'm very tired but it's good
it's very very good we've put in a lot
of work into it and I'm very proud of
where it is and if you can be there on
Sunday you can see it I am going to give
you a little teaser of it and I am going
to show you some of our hard work that
is if there was nothing wrong with the
render because like I said there's no
time there's just no time I have to
leave almost immediately
so while people filter in thank you so
much for your patience I know I said I
was just going to get back into regular
videos and then suddenly I found myself
working on a project for my mom but if
you know my mom and if you know me
I'll do anything for family
and that's very important and that's
what this is about
um yes I am going to show you a little
bit what's going on uh I am in a hurry
there is absolutely no time for this
Preamble or for me to take questions or
anything like that I'm going to show you
in less than a minute a snippet of the
documentary that I've been working on
for my mom called Markiplier from North
Korea it is going to be uh watched live
together with you guys on Sunday link is
in the description below there is a link
in the description you're going to get a
little teaser of it now and you're gonna
see that and you're gonna see what
you're in store for but until Sunday
happens you don't get the full picture
and you don't get the full story so
remember this Sunday Link in the
description all of it goes towards my
mom there's also merch there if you
didn't know and there's a q a session
but if you want to be there for the full
experience and if you want to support my
mom and you don't want to support her
and myself you're going to be there on
Sunday Link in the description now
given that I am uh completely out of
time I'm going to show you exactly what
you have in store with a little bit of a
clip
so that you can be there at the same
time
everybody ready
everybody here you'll be there well
you'll be there to see this because if
you're not
my mom will be disappointed
I say I was born in Korea yeah
absolutely whatever you want say
whatever comes naturally okay yes um
because that's it's more important just
to like
make this feel like story time because
when think of when you're on your
Instagram live and you're you're just
talking like that's all this is okay I
usually don't get this nervous there's
nothing to be nervous about I mean
Ethan's here I did it but yeah I'm very
scary all right here we go
state your name for the record
yes my name is Sanuk Frank
how do you know this mysterious
Markiplier
well it's my son
as you know is this story about me
or is it about you well actually
it's all above
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wants to know dearly I know especially
your childhood but for us to be here in
America I want to share the story where
we came from
and away we started it is about you it's
also about your ancestor including my
life your life
my father's
life
who begin this journey for us to live in
this country
with many opportunities
do you know what clickbait is I I know
right so would you say this title is
clipping yes and no foreign
that's all you get I don't have time for
anything else this is the final reminder
until I get over there and I'm able to
finalize everything for Sunday I might
have another one of these
tomorrow what day is today I don't even
remember it's been a little bit of a
Sleepless time here so I have to go
because I have to leave pretty much
immediately thank you all so much for
supporting my mom and being there on
Sunday and I'll see you there and if
you're for the Q a session I will see
you a little bit before but remember the
link is in the description tell
everybody about it because this is to
support my mom and my family
I'm gonna go but thank you so much for
being here I don't have time for sleep I
know many of you are probably telling me
to but I don't have time for that
there's no time for anything there's no
time to waste you gotta click the link
in the description below
or else you will forever disappoint my
mom
and to anyone that disappoints my mom
I will find you
and I will make you pay